en tunisie le président queille sayed
met en garde contre une tentative
d'assassinât contre lui et des hauts
fonctionnaires les menace émanerait
d'après lui de ses opposants aussi bien
à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du pays
le chef de l'état de plus en plus isolé
ne cesse d'exacerber les tensions depuis
son coup de force du 25 juillet date à
laquelle au nom de la lutte contre la
corruption il a gelé le parlement et
limoger le gouvernement on fait le point
avec notre correspondant à tunis bassin
chebbi un conseil des ministres aux
allures de réunion de crise hier soir au
palais de carthage entouré des membres
du gouvernement le président de la
république a mis en garde son équipe et
l'ensemble de la population tunisienne
contre d'éventuels projets d'assassinât
organisé par ce qu'il qualifie de
traître après être revenu sur ses
projets de réformes et sa lutte contre
la corruption le chef de l'état assuré
sur un ton ferme qu'il était au courant
de l'ensemble des complots préparer à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur du
territoire évoquant des tentatives
visant à faire échouer son projet pour
la tunisie écoutez je le dis devant tout
le monde il y à des complots qui se
trament et qui vont jusqu'à la
suggestion d'assassinât les tunisiens
doivent être vigilants et attentifs aux
plans trafiquées par certains traître
vendu aux services de renseignement pour
exécuter un nombre de responsables nous
savons ce qui se trame à l'intérieur et
à l'étranger nous sommes au courant de
l'existence d'un appel téléphonique qui
évoque la date même de ces assassinats
depuis son coup de force du 25 juillet
la mise en place des mesures
exceptionnelles est les rangs de
l'opposition contre le jour après jour
discréditant davantage à l'action du
président de la république qu'il soit de
la société civile ou de la classe
politique tous dénoncent une violation
des libertés et des acquis de la
révolution de 2011 par un homme qui
centralise à lui seul tous les pouvoirs
l'organisation internationale human
rights watch a mis en garde contre
certaines violations flagrantes des
libertés à commencer par la
multiplication des procès militaires et
civils pour offense au président écoute
et critiqué publiquement le président
suite à son accaparement de pouvoirs
additionnels c'est prendre le risque de
finir devant un tribunal faire taire les
critiques représente un double danger à
l'heure où le président est occupé à
concentrer tant de pouvoirs entre ses
mains
faisant fi de toute critique l homme
fort de la tunisie est bien décidée à
maintenir son cap dans un pays qui
s'enlise davantage dans une crise
économique et politique sans précédent